hi guys i'm anjali from simply learn now
if you have been following our playlist
on python
by now you have probably completed all
the basic concepts of python so today
we'll use these basic concepts in
creating a website
using python again now this application
is called django
and before we move into actually
developing the website let's better
understand what django is so django
is a high level python web framework so
when you compare django to many of its
other counterparts
such as flask which also uses python it
provides
very limited freedom but then again this
limited freedom does mean that it makes
development much faster and that is the
goal of django so if you are a complete
beginner
with web development and also sort of
with python
this is the place to start so django has
a free and a paid version
but since you are just learning how it
works we can go for the free
version in fact the paid version is only
required when it's utilized by companies
where they perform a lot of
modifications to the point that it's
actually unrecognizable now some of the
companies which are using django
are instagram bitbucket pinterest and
even nasa now there's another
important thing that we need to
understand about django which is its
design
pattern so django follows the mtv design
pattern where mtv stands for model
template view
these terms may seem very remote to you
right now and i don't think there'd be a
point of me explaining what they
are as of now so once we move on to the
demo
where i'll be teaching how you can
create the web framework we can better
understand
how this design pattern works and with
that we are finally ready to move into
actually creating
our website so there are certain
prerequisites to django
to perform these open your command
prompt so the first thing we need to
ensure is that your system has python
installed now of course if you are
learning django you probably already
know python
and for this purpose you would have had
python installed previously itself
we'll just check so type in python
version and
if you do have python installed your
version number will appear here
now the other thing we need installed is
pip so once again
pip would also be installed on your
systems it comes with python itself
and so yeah i have pip 19.0.2 version
now once those two things are done we'll
move on to a virtual environment
so a virtual environment is basically
this environment that we create
to isolate our application now this is
necessary in django because often
we make applications we have completely
built the application and now we do not
want to touch them we do not want to
create
anything new we do not want to update
any packages that are already being used
so if you are creating a new
application for which you need to update
the packages we don't want the
implementation of that
to hamper with the implementation of our
current application so this is why we
completely isolate them so for that the
first thing you do is you need to
install the virtual environment wrapper
we'll use the pip command to do so so
pip install
virtual env wrapper so if you're using
any other system such as linux systems
and then press enter but in case of
windows
put a dash and win which signifies
windows so i already have my virtual
environment installed so now we have
python we have our pip and we have the
virtual environment now let's create a
virtual environment
so to create the virtual environment
type in
mk virtual env and the name for your
virtual environment
so previously i had made in virtual
environment py1 this time i'll go with
py2
and that should create your environment
so a virtual environment is created
which is p
by two and as soon as it's created
you'll notice that now your commands
start running in pyto so
when you're creating an application the
application itself
is not created at this place it's just
the environment files that's stored in
here so now all this is done
the final prerequisite is of course to
have
our web framework we need to install
django so let's get to that
pip install django so now that django is
installed we are finally ready to start
our project so the command to run to
start your first project
django dash admin start project
and followed by the name of your project
so i'll just name my project
django project so i just cleared my
screen
now if you go to this location where we
created our project
you'll see the project folder is created
here and
inside the folder there's yet another
folder with the same project name and a
manage file now this manage file
is usually what we will be running to
compile our programs
and then within the folder you have
certain python files
so we'll open all this in our ide and
i'll be using pycharm but you can go
ahead with any other python id
in fact you can even use a notebook so
you can select your project from here
the panel on the left or you can opt for
open
browse through your folders and then
select your project so the project we
created just now
is the django project which is this one
so i'll
open it and and your project will appear
on the left side panel here you can see
within it there's another folder with
the same project name
and there's the manage.py file now
within this folder again there's another
folder dot
idea and then there is the init settings
url and the wsgi file although we won't
be making changes
on modifying any of these files so we'll
check out what these files
are one by one although we won't be
making modifications to most of them
the idea folder probably won't be
existing in your project you can
completely ignore that now we'll have a
look
at what each of these python files do so
the first file which is the init file as
you can see it's empty
the reason is that the very presence of
this file is only to
inform that this package here this is
not
any ordinary folder it's a python
package so you don't really need any
content within this
now the next file that we have here is
the settings file so the settings file
is essential configuration file this is
modified only when your application goes
into the real world other than that we
just leave it as it is so some of the
values that you would be modifying
is for example the debug value now when
the debug value is true which in our
case it is
whenever an error occurs in any of your
code and you're trying to run that page
all the errors appear on the page but
now if you are
putting your website into the real world
you do not want that all your errors
will be displayed on the page for
obviously security reasons so then you
can just change this value to false
just before you upload your page next
you have the urls page
as from the name it's very clear the
urls page is where you have your url
stored so basically
this file maps the url of a page to the
function that the page will be
performing so now you have the wsgi dot
py code file so this page contains an
application callable which the
application
server uses to communicate with your
code and finally we have the manage dot
py page
this is the page used to interact with
your project so we never
ever touch the manage.py page the
settings page does
change when your website goes into the
real world
the urls page we will be actually
modifying during the course of our
project
again the wsgy dot py page we leave it
untouched
so now that you know the basics of what
each file already present
does we can start our demo so before we
start
coding our website there's a dummy
development
server which is provided with django so
we'll just check that out first
just go to your command prompt and move
into the path of your project
and then you just type python manage dot
py
run server and as you can see here the
development server has started and it's
at
port 8000 so go to your browser
open any browser of your choice
localhost
and at 8 000 put and as you can see here
since we have
installed our django and we ran our
server so
our django page has appeared here and it
says that our installation
worked successful so so far all good we
can now start building our project
so what website are we creating well i
was thinking of a very
basic website where you'll have the
front page the first page would have
probably like three four genres and
within each genre
you'll have a piece that is an article a
novel or even a poem
of that particular genre so the user
gets to click the genre on the first
page and the minute he or she does so we
move on to the next page
where we have our article within that
genre
displayed we'll also include a
registration page
just to see how that works with django
so before we move on guys i want to tell
you that this tutorial will completely
concentrate on how django works so we
will not look much
into the details of how our page is
displayed that is we won't go
in depth into html css and so on but
rather just stick to django and its
functionality
and another thing that we need to know
about django
before we start developing is that every
page
in django is called an app so when you
go to a website
say facebook for instance you have
multiple tabs right
so there's a tab for the profile you
click on it and it immediately takes you
to your profile now if this entire thing
that is facebook was built on django
then your profile would be one app
and then there's another tab which takes
you to your messages
the page where all your messages are
displayed that would be a second app so
that's how django works
every small thing every component or
every page of your website
is an app and you need to ensure that
you can describe
exactly what an app does in one or two
sentences
so a page should not have multiple
things happening on it if a page is for
displaying messages
that should be the sole purpose of the
page so yeah that's the basic of
apps and how they are a part of django
so how do we create this app
just open your command prompt move on to
the path where your project is stored
now in here you'll type in the command
to create your first
app so that's python manage dot py
start app and then the name for your app
so i'll name my app genre so basically
on my first page i want all my genres to
be displayed and
every article is put under a particular
journal hence the name
enter and your app should be created so
i go back to my pycharm and as you can
see here
we have our app genre created in here
now under this
app there are more number of files so
what do these files do
we'll discuss that first well first is
our migrations
folder now inside this migration folder
there will be a number of files
which will be created once we go through
our project we'll see every time we
execute a particular command a new file
is inserted into the migrations folder
so this basically connects your database
with your source code and that
might seem very complicated but actually
django makes it extremely easy
and then you have the admins page now
this admin file or this admin
page that django provides is extremely
useful so it's like this dummy admin
page
where you can actually go and you can
view your entire database there in a
very formatted way
you have all the models that you created
there you can insert more values you can
delete values you can edit values which
are already present so right
now the admin page will not be existing
there's no point of us going and
checking it right now since we have not
created any models yet
again what is models i'll come to that
too so that is the next file i'll be
telling you about now if you have gone
through object oriented programming
python or java or any other
object-oriented programming as a matter
of fact you probably know the concept of
classes
now over here in our models file we
create classes
and each of this class is actually a
model and by that
we mean it's a database so when we
create a class we have a number of
attributes in this class and each of
this attribute forms a column in our
database
so that is what will be happening here
and once we create our class
or what we call model that is when we
can actually view
the admin page and we'll see how this
page is extremely helpful
the next important page is the views
page so guys if you remember initially i
told you that django has
a design pattern which is the model view
template where model is already
discussed
they are the classes template as you
probably guessed
is the look of the page so that's
basically your html files and
what brings the model and the template
together
that is the view so view adds the
functionality now whenever you receive a
request from the user for a particular
url
you will describe the response for this
request but
view is not responsible for giving the
response that is another file that we'll
be creating
as you'll see in some time so now when i
go back to my web page here
there's no url for this this is just a
domain name but once we start creating a
website
the very existence of each web page is
linked to a presence of a url so that is
exactly where we'll start building
under our django project folder we have
this urls page there's already a url
path present here
it says admin which is as you guessed
it's the url to the admin page
that is by default provided by django
and over here there's this another
parameter so what this parameter is
it's the response that is to be given
for the request that you receive
now just in this manner we need to add
the url for our first page which is
going to be the genres page so i say
path genres and then in here i'll insert
the action
so i've not created any action yet so i
don't know what to put in there either
as of now but guys think about this so
if our website
has 10 pages does this mean that we'll
have
10 different urls going in here that
would be quite
half a sad wouldn't it so we need a more
organized way of doing this
and for that very purpose we will use
genres
the app as our base app so if from
genres we are moving on to our second
page so say our genres has our three
genres which is fiction
inspiration and something else so user
clicks on fiction
and this immediately takes the user to
the second page
where the content in fiction is
displayed
so then our second page should be a sub
page of genre in a way
and every other page that we move to
from our first page
should be the same so for this purpose
what we can do is we'll go to our genres
app
the package we'll create another urls
file
within journal and in this urls file
we'll define
the url for our second page with
reference to
our genres url so how is that done well
the first thing you need to do
is you must copy paste this statement
here into our urls page
for this page we do not really need to
import include so i'll remove
that part out and i also need to define
my urls pattern so
copy paste this too but again admin is
already defined there completely we do
not require that
now here we'll say if the user wants the
page genres
this is going to be my first page that
is my front page
so what will be the response to this the
response will
obviously be defined in our views page
right now we have not created anything
in our views page
but we will soon and we will name the
response for
the url jonas as index since that is
usually what the
purpose of the front page is it's
usually to display the index
so we'll have view dot index and then
following this we'll also give a name to
this very particular
call and the purpose of that i will
explain later
just name this index for now it's not
view its views
and also we need to now import views
okay so we defined that if the user goes
to this page genre
then we will be displaying whatever is
defined
under views.index of course we have not
created that yet and we'll move on to
that in a while now the problem
is every request that is made by the
user
the first thing django does is it checks
the urls page
under your main project which is this
page and under this page
we have not defined the action for
genres and it would be very repetitive
to define this again
so what we do instead is we'll just
include
the file where we did define the
function for genres and that is genres
dot urls
so the user gives a request for the
genres page
django checks out this main url speech
it sees
it matches the url to this very
particular pattern here
and for that it knows that the response
is to include the genres dot url page so
it includes this page and within this
page we of course have the function or
the response defined
so now the next thing is to create the
response
so now under this views file will create
a view the first thing
is we need to import the http package
the request is always http
and this time the response that we are
providing is also a http response we'll
change this later because we'll need a
more defined response but for now we'll
stick to a very
basic display on our first web page so
let's
import django.http
import http response and now we can
define
a function which will tell what response
to provide for the particular urls
now here we say that if the user
gives a request for this url our
response is views.index
so within views we need to define a
function named
index so def index and this one
takes request as a parameter and returns
a http response and that response could
be
a simple text of course you can also
have html tags and just for the purpose
of formatting so that our text looks
pretty bold
i'll put this into a header just say
hello world
so that's done this is the response that
we'll be providing for that particular
url
now the thing is we have this page here
settings and
in settings if you scroll down you'll
see there's a list of
apps which are installed and in this
list our app
genre is not mentioned so before we run
our server
we'll add our app to this list so that's
done
now go to your web page the one where
you run your local host first and
this time okay so my server is not
running i need to start my server first
type in your command
python manage dot py run
server and it says that there's no issue
and our server is
currently running so you go back to the
page where we run our local host
so the last thing we ran a local host
currently your page would still be on
that if you have not
done any modifications i did a few in
between hence i got this page
now if you check out localhost again
you'll see that there's an
error this because now we started
defining the urls
in our url page so when you don't give
any url as such
django checks out the two urls defined
here
and says hey what you typed in here
whatever your request was
does not match any of the url patterns
so now we want to check out the genres
page
and enter and as you see here hello
world is displayed so of course this is
a dummy page
we need to do something way more we need
to create a webpage
and that is what we'll get to okay so
now that we viewed our dummy web page
the next thing we need to do is actually
populate this app with some data now to
populate the app with data
of course we need to first store the
data and that is stored in a database
so with django you would have probably
already noticed here
this is file called sqlite3 so this is
the database management system that
comes
along with django it's already set up to
be used
just a small command a small tweak that
we require
and everything will work perfectly fine
so what this does
is basically all the data that you enter
through your model
will work along with this so that means
that there should be a communication
between your sqlite and your source code
now if i go back to the terminal where i
ran
my server you'll see here there's an
error line which says you have 15
unapplied migrations and your project
may not work properly
right now what we designed worked right
because we didn't have any data stored
but
from now on we will be storing data so
we need to ensure
that the migrations are done right and
by migrations we mean that
our database management that sqlite is
synced pretty well
with our source code so first of all
stop your server
and now you run a command to do the
syncing which is python
manage dot py migrate and as you hit
this command
the syncing is happening so when you say
that the migrations are complete
what you actually mean is when django
looks at your installed apps this is an
app that we created and we just added it
a while back
to this list of installed apps but
everything else in here
in this list was already present so
these are some default apps with django
or this project in particular will
already work with and
many of these apps require to access
some databases
it could not do that until now but now
that we've finished our migrations
when django checks out these apps and
needs to run them it can easily access
the database
take whatever data is required from
there and perform its functions
again if we go back to our command
prompt and run the server again
you'll see that this time we do not get
the error of the
unapplied migrations so that is how you
sync your database
with your source code now once we create
our models
it means that we have added some new
classes there are some new tables which
are going to be added so again we need
to perform the migration function which
we'll look into later
now let's get to creating our classes so
as i mentioned earlier models are
basically classes now there are two
classes that we will be
creating for this particular project the
first class
will have all the genres and the second
class which will hold all the articles
so let's begin coding
now my first class i'll call it
collection and every class needs to
import from models
dot model now within this class all we
need to define are its various
attributes
so i'll explain this again the class is
basically a table
and all your attributes of the
particular class are the columns
so the first thing is the collection
name or the genre name
now the collection name would be
something like a fiction
or inspiration or non-fiction could be
anything
and all these are strings so when you're
inputting them
so in django basically that's the cache
field type so you say
models dot care field and a compulsory
parameter here is you have to
insert the maximum length i'll give it
100 characters
next thing we'll have a description for
each genotype
that again would be carefield enter a
max length
give it 500 and then we'll also have an
image
or a cover for each of the collection or
each of the genre
so that would be i'd say call cover as
in collection cover
so this again will be a careful type as
i'm going to enter the link
for the image over here now the links
would be pretty large
so i'd say a length of thousand
so that's our first class now we'll
define a second class
which is for the particular articles or
the pieces which are inside the
collection so here we'll just go for one
article
within a collection and i'll name this
class as
piece as in a piece within a collection
again this class to impose from
models.model and we will enter the
column names now so every
piece will have a title which would be
the name
of the piece and that too would be of
care field type
give the sir 200 and then all of these
will have a particular type that is
whether
it's a book it's a novel it's a poem or
it's a blog post
that is what will go in our type
variable next we'll have the artist name
for a book that would be an author for a
poem that would be a poet
so we'll go for the general term which
is artist the year
it was published now the year would be
an integer
so we have a different field type here
the integer field
and that does not require a max link and
finally
again for each piece you'll have a cover
so i'll name that
piece cover again we'll pass the link of
an image here
so carefield with the max length of
thousand
and yeah so our two models are created
here
class collection and class piece now
once again we'll do the migration
and what will happen is that the
database will link with this model
and then we can finally view the admin
page
and see what exactly that admin page is
that we've been talking about all this
while
but before we move on we are missing out
on something so we have our collection
and we have each piece how do we link
the piece
with the collection well this is where
the concepts that you probably learned
in database
is gonna come into use this is where
we'll use a foreign key
so although we are writing a code here
this is exactly how
a table in a database will be created so
every item
would have a primary key and now we are
going to use foreign keys
in our class piece to link each piece to
a particular collection so if i say dan
brown's book origin
so that should be linked through the
foreign key with
our collection fiction so let's create
our foreign key and
i'll name it collection but this time
with a small seat
models dot foreign key so to the foreign
key you pass the table name
to which you're making the reference
first which is collection
and then you pass on an action as to
what will happen to a particular piece
if the collection that it's linked to
is deleted so what we want is if suppose
fiction is deleted then automatically
origin
which is tied with fiction should also
be deleted and that
is called a cascade delete so you say on
delete
models dot cascade and now we are
finally done
creating our models so now that our
models are created
we know these particular models are
created for our
application or our app genre so you go
back to the settings page
and here we had previously inserted this
app genre but
back then it was not really required it
was just that there is
this other app that is not included in
the default apps given by
django so let's put in the name there
but now that we actually
have a database associated with this app
we need to specify this app in its
complete structure
that is the configuration so if you go
under genres
and then there's this file apps and
under
apps you can see this class genre config
copy this go back to settings so genre
dot
apps dot genre config so now
when you run your server django will
check the list of installed apps and
will be able to access the database
associated with
our newly created app too but there's
more to it than that
remember how previously we made
migrations so we can
link our database with the source code
now we got to make those migrations
again
because now we created new models so
every time you create
a model or you make some changes to your
models
you always need to do your migrations
and this time
since our migrations is specific to a
particular app the syntax is slightly
different
so you can also use this terminal down
here it works just the same
and python manage dot py
make migrations and your app name enter
and as you see it says the models
collection
and piece have been created now what
this migrations
exactly does is it converts these models
that you have written in coded format
into an
sql form so that's where your tables and
everything stored
and now if you check your migrations
folder you'll see there's a new file
under it that is a current migration
that you
attempted so now that the migrations are
made you can finally
run your project so once again and
overall migrations
so i'm back to my command prompt since
the
black background makes it easier to see
the text
break out of your server and we finished
our migration so now we can
run our server no issues and there's no
error with the migrations either
let's now check out our genre page of
course it'll look the same
because although we created our models
what the models will be reflected
in is the database the overall look of
the page so far has not been changed so
it's the same
so i'll repeat that once again every
time you make a change to your model
or you add some new class to your model
first run the migrations for that
particular
app that is python manage dot py make
migrations
and your app name and then you run a
migrations in general so that's python
manage.py
migrations and then you can run your
server okay so
our database is created but right now
it's empty so our next step is to
populate our database
for that again open a command prompt and
now you need to enter
into the sql shell so the command for
that
is python manage dot py
shell but before that i'll just go to
the path
where my project is stored and now in
here i'll
execute my command so once you get these
three
arrows you know that you have entered
the shell and over here
you can execute your sql commands now
before we
input values into our tables what we
need to do
is we have to import these tables
because even within this project there
are multiple number of tables there are
some tables which were
in there by default too so from genre
dot
models import collection comma
piece which are the name of our tables
and enter
so our tables are now imported now first
we'll populate our table collection okay
so
collection has three columns there's the
collection name
there's a description and there's a
cover image so
go back to your shell so we'll have an
object here
collection one which will be equal to
collection
so this would be the constructor for
our class collection and within this
we'll insert our values
so our first attribute is collection
name
and that's equal to fiction our second
attribute is the description
and we'll say enter the world
of fantasies for the description of
fiction and finally we have the
attribute called cover
which is the collection cover and in
here i'll just
enter the url of an image i found online
so that's it we have entered the values
for our three attributes
now press enter now let's view if this
is actually stored in our database so
for that
you execute the command your table name
which is collection
dot objects dot all and it's
empty so what's wrong we created an
object in which we inserted all the
values but then still
our database seems to be empty so this
is because
so far this collection object that we
created
is only stored in our shells memory we
have not
actually committed this to the database
so the command
for committing this to the database
would be our object name which is call
one dot
save and once again we'll execute the
command to check everything that's
present
in our database collection and now you
can see finally that there is an
object present and now we can also check
the value of the various columns
in our table collection for this
particular object
you can say call 1 dot collection name
and gives you the collection name
similarly you can also check its
description
now as i mentioned previously every
object that you create in a table
has a primary key associated with it so
the primary key basically holds the
uniqueness of that particular row so we
can also check the primary key for a
particular row
or an object just go for call 1 dot
pk and it says the primary key is one
now the primary key is also known as the
id of the object
so you can identify it as id2
again you'll get the value which is one
now if you want to change the value
of any of these columns that can also be
done very easily on the shell
so suppose i want to change the
description say call 1
dot description and initially it was
enter the world of fantasies i wanted to
be welcome to the world
of fantasies so welcome to the world
of fantasies and now if i check the
value
of call one.description the value has
changed
so that's pretty simple isn't it now if
you think this is simple there's a much
much more simpler way of adding values
to the database
which we'll see just in a while and that
is where we'll
put in more objects we'll have a few
more genres and we'll also add elements
to our table piece
so now we can look into how to create
our admin page so now that we learned
how to input or populate our database
through the shell let's go for the
easier and the more efficient way which
is through the admin now before we do
that we need to create a admin
and for that go to your command prompt
out
of the shell now in your command prompt
type the command
python manage dot py create
super user okay so once you do that
they'll ask you to create a username
and we'll just go for admin since we're
creating ourself as the admin
enter enter an email id just go with
admin 123
at admin.com and a password
so since this is not a production
environment i'm gonna just bypass the
password validation
but if your website is going into the
real world
then make sure things are secure enough
and our super user is created
successfully
so now we can go on to a browser and
here we'll just type admin so this is
our admin page
you can see here there are two tabs
groups and users
but the main thing the main reason that
we require the admin page does not
seem to come out here we expected there
to be our database tables present here
so we can directly go
and edit them or add some values to them
but it's not there
so what is missing is that we need to go
back to our python page
and over here go down to the admin
file so here we need to add the models
that we want
to appear in the admin page basically we
need to register those models with the
admin page
and for that the first thing we do is we
have to import the model
so from dot models import
and our two classes are
collection and peace so we have not
added anything to our table piece yet
we will later on but any how we'll just
register both of them at one shot
and you type in here admin dot site dot
register collection
copy paste this and change the
collection to
piece which is our second table and
that's it so
with just these two lines of code you
should have your collection
and your piece tables appearing in the
admin page
now when i move back to the admin page
and refresh this
you'll see that our tables have appeared
here
click on collection and there's one
collection object here
click on that you can see the values of
the attributes
and through this admin page now i'll
show you how you can
add more objects so just press
on save and add another here we can
enter our second collection's name
which in my case is inspiration and
description would be
inspired to do more and for call
cover which is the collection cover i
have another link that i just
took from the net save and we'll add one
more
so we'll have three collections now and
our third collection
would be horror the description let's
say
the fear is real although we hope it's
not
and finally we have the collection cover
paste the link here
save the store so now we have three
objects under collection
now as you see here all our collection
objects
just say collection object with the
number in bracket
in the similar manner when we were also
going through our
shell every time we executed the command
collection.objects.all
we got just the name collection object
and a number
but we want something more meaningful so
when i look
at this table of collections i know that
the first one
is the collection fiction the second one
is
the collection inspiration and so on so
for that
go back to your code so go under your
models
dot py file and under the class
collection
we'll define a special method which is
double underscore
str now this is an overriding method
that is this method
already defined but the value returned
by this method
is not of much meaning to us as if now
so now
over here we'll return something that we
actually want to see
when we look at the objects in our table
collection
and what i want is i want the collection
name to appear
that would be quite clear as to what
object
is at which position so i say collection
return self dot collection name and that
should do it
now in the similar manner we can have
the same function
for ps2 and for peace what we want to
return
is the title so that's it now if i go
back to my admin page
refresh this as you can see we have
something much more meaningful
under our table collection now the
objects actually have a name well the
objects don't actually have a name but
we are displaying one of the attributes
of the object
and that gives more clarity as to what
the object holds
so now we'll start creating our views
now as i mentioned earlier
our website would be such that the first
page that the user goes to
is probably going to be the genres page
which will have the url
genre and with nothing following it so
the function for that particular url or
the response for that particular url
we defined in here in our urls page
under the genres app
which is we'll be calling the index
function in views
that is this function now from that page
there will be certain links and when the
user clicks those links
he or she can move to another webpage
and that
is the webpage where the particular
article present
inside our collection would be displayed
so
i'll just put down in comment what
pattern of the url we are matching for
each of these path so the first one that
we are matching
is just genre followed by nothing now
our next path
would be genre followed by a number now
this
number one here is actually the id of
the collection that the user chooses
so if the user chooses the collection
fiction which is our first collection
that has a primary key one so
immediately the user should be sent
to the next web page which is genre
1 where 1 represents the id of the
collection chosen by the user
so now for path let's pass
the expression that will match this
particular url
and that expression is actually just an
integer number
since the front part that is genre slash
is already matched and this integer
number we
are going to store it in a variable
because we will require that
variable later so you can just say int
colon
and collection id now when you do this
and jonas id so when you do this
what happens is that this one gets
stored in this variable
genre id and this pattern will match
this
url now when this url is matched what
response do you want to give that is
what you want to display on that
particular web page
that will be defined in another function
we'll define
under views we'll name it details for
now of course details is not defined
we'll do that in a while
and give a name to this too which will
be the same details
so now we are able to recognize this url
what we need to do is next we need to
define details which will give a
response to that url
so go to your views page and you create
your details function now what is
displayed in this details function
greatly depends
upon the genre that is chosen by the
user in the first page
which is stored again in genres id so
over here
you pass not only the request but also
genre
id and inside you'll return a http
response
the collection the genre id
is the html tags also need to be within
the quotes
copy paste that in here have code here
too
and now one more thing we need to do is
so genre's
id is an integer but we cannot
concatenate an integer with a string
so we need to convert this to a string
and that's
it so let's go back to our web page and
run this
page so the first page which is genres
displays hello world
now if i enter genre slash 1 which is
what we created newly
run the code you see here the genre id
is 1.
in a similar manner even if i enter 5
although we don't
have a collection five it'll display the
genre ids five
now these are dummy web pages so this
kind of
a display is fine of course once we
actually start building our view
which we will do very soon things will
be more defined
now let's get to actually creating a
good view
so what we want here is uh first of all
we do not want to
display any large text so let's delete
that
off we need to import our models
because this is where our database is
and of course we need to fetch
information from our database to be
displayed on our view
so from dot models
import collection and peace now in our
index function what we'll do is we'll
first
collect all the objects from our table
collection
we'll have a variable which is all
collection and then to collect all the
objects we'll use the same
sql command that we used so so that's
collection
dot objects so all your objects in the
collection table will be stored in all
collection
now we'll store this as a dictionary so
that we can iterate over
these objects and display them one by
one so we say context
equal to all collection is the
key and the value would be our variable
all collection
so that's done now we need to iterate
over this
so do we do that within our views itself
but there's no point of doing that
because
while we are iterating over every object
in our collection table we also need to
display them
in a certain format that means that we
need these objects to be somehow
embedded
in a html file and this is where
we create our very first html file for
our first page
which is the genres page so to create
our html page
inside genre create another package
and you name this package templates now
inside templates
create another folder and give this
package the name
same name as your app name that is genre
and now
inside genre we can create a html file
i'll name this file genre template
so all our template or our html files
will be
in this path okay so before we actually
develop the genre template
html file we'll go back to our view and
complete the section of
so now what we are seeing is that we
have a template
we have a html file and that file will
define
how we need to display the objects in
our collection database
or our collection table all we need to
do here in our index function
is actually pass these objects to our
html file
so for this we have a function render
and before we actually use the function
we need to import the library
django.shortcuts
under which we have this function render
this is already imported on top
i did not see that so i'll just remove
that part out
and now that you have the render
function you use that
to pass your object so what this render
function does is basically
we'll pass context to it it will type
context
with the template name that we pass and
it will return
a http response object so you pass your
request
you pass the path to your template that
is genre
slash templates slash genre
slash genre template genretemplate.html
so now you have passed your template to
and
finally the object which is context
so that's pretty much all you need to do
for your very first view
under the views file now we need to
develop our genres template
so for our html file first thing we'll
change the title
let's display our app name so in this
particular case since i'm making a dummy
website i'm not giving it a name or
anything
just going with our app name okay so now
we need to display our objects which
have been passed from the views folder
now the render
function basically passes an object
which is called
object underscore list so we'll create
a for loop say collection in
object underscore list so this way we
can iterate through
all the objects in our object list and
now see this is an
html file but this line of code here
this is the python code so
pretty often this will happen that you
need to embed a python code
within your html file so what you do is
you insert your python code
within curly brace followed by the
percentage sign this will tell your
compiler that hey
although this is a html file this line
here
is actually a python instruction so now
we're able to extract each genre
in fact i'll name this variable as
genre obj now we need to decide how
exactly we want to display these objects
so what i want is first i want the image
of that particular collection or the
genre to be displayed
which is what i have stored in one of
the variables and then
just below the image i want the name of
the genre to be displayed now this name
should be clickable so that the minute
the user clicks on it we can move on to
another page
and then just below the name i want the
description for that genre to be
displayed
okay so first we have the image img
source and in here i need to insert the
link for that particular image so the
link
i actually already stored in my database
as i showed we did that through the
shell and then later on through the
admin page too so how do we
access that particular link well just
like you would in a python code
you can access it through the variable
name and every time
you're accessing or you're displaying
just the value
of a variable you insert the variable
name within double braces
so double braces and then genre obj
dot call cover and now i'll give it some
height and width to make it look a
little more appealing
we'll have minimal formatting here
because the objective of this
tutorial is not to show you how to write
your html code
but how django works and next i'll have
the name
as i said this particular name would be
clickable
so inside href i will insert the
url of the page the user should be taken
to
once he clicks on the name so that url
is what we defined here okay so it's
genre followed by
the primary key or the id of the
category that he clicked
so that would be genre slash
and we stored it in genre id
so that's the link the user will be
taken to and now
the name that will be displayed and then
after that
finally we have the description to be
displayed so that'll be
in a h3 header again double braces
because
we are going to just print out the value
of a variable
and then after each object's details are
displayed we'll break a line
for better formatting what i'll do is
i'll have all of this
embedded within a div and have it
aligned to the center so that's it we
have created a html file here
one more thing i'll just say end for
so that's it our html file or our
complete display for the first page
has been created so once again i'll
explain what will happen
in the case of our first page only
when the user enters the url
genre followed by nothing django will
first
check this urls page the main url page
you'll see the path has matched here
and the action for this has been defined
as you
include the genres.url page so it goes
to the genres.url page
includes this and in this there's a
function defined
as a response for this particular url a
very well defined
function which is in our views file so
it goes to the views file
and in the views file we have completely
defined our function
index over here we collect all the
objects in our collection table
we convert that into a dictionary so
that it's iterable
then we pass it using the render
function so the render function
will take your template and it will tie
that along with
the context which is the dictionary and
it will
pass an object a response object
to a html file this response object
will be called object.list and it is
iterable
so we'll iterate through the object we
will display each
object in a sort of formatted way
and that is it and then the render
function will pass this object
all collection to our template and over
here we will iterate
over the all collection which is the
dictionary
and using this hashtable code here we'll
print out
the objects in all collection in a
formatted way
so that's it and one more thing
make a small correction back in the
views file
so initially i had inserted the entire
path to
genretemplate.html so the thing with the
render function
is that it automatically knows that it
must look into the templates folder so
you have to only give the path
after the template that's genre genre
template now let's go back
to our browser and in here
put in your url and there you go
so that's our first web page you can see
the image
for our genre is here and then you have
the name
and then you have the description okay
so that's
redirecting us to a page where there's
an error
it says that this path is not found so
when you look at these error guys you
will understand better as to how the
matching
of the url patterns take place first
this url pattern
just this part after your port number
that
is checked against the url in your main
url file that is django
projects.url file where we have defined
genre and then after that it will check
the files that we included in the genres
url file
that is genre followed by the genre id
now we had defined a dummy page for this
previously and that was being displayed
too
so i'll go back to the code and figure
out what the error is
the error is here of course i wrote
genre id
which does not signify anything as such
now because here we have this object
genre obj that is where all the objects
from the collection
table are stored one by one so what we
actually need to access
is the id for genre obj now i'll go back
to my browser so now i'm back to my
browser and as you can see here
we still have our front page click on
fiction
and yeah we got our dummy page back so
now our next step is to design
this page go back to your code and
again designing the page means we
need to start putting content into our
details function
now before we start designing this
function we need to populate the piece
table
so again let's go back to our admin page
we'll
add the data through the admin page
since that's much easier
here you have piece and click on the add
button
first we'll add for fiction the title
will give
let's insert the book origin
by dan brown so the artist would be dan
brown
and it's a novel and the year is 2017.
that's the year of publication
and for the piece cover i'll just put
the book origins
front page cover i'll just put in the
image here
a link save and add another
now for inspiration i'll put in the poem
if
and type would be poem artist is
rudyard kipling kipling with single p
the year of publication would be 1895
and for the peace cover another link
and finally we'll add one to horror
the title would be the pet symmetry
written by stephen king and again this
is a novel
it's published in the year 1983
and then link and we save this so we are
done for each
of the categories or each of the genre
we have added
a single article so now that our table
piece
is also populated we can start designing
the view for this
so for our details page let's start with
removing this http response here
so first what we need to do is we need
to extract
the object that the user selected
from our genres page so we say
collection
dot objects dot get
pk equal to genre id
so what we are doing here is as you can
see above we use
the query collection.objects.all which
returned all the objects in our table
collection now
here we are telling that okay i want
just one object from my collections
table
and that particular object is the one
whose primary key
matches that stored in the variable
genre.id
and since genre.id is defined
in this file and it's basically the id
of the genre that the user selected
this will be a number either one two or
three
that is one for fiction two for
inspiration and 3 for horror
so now that we got that object we will
use this
object c item to extract
from a piece table so for that we say
piece dot object dot filter
and to this we pass and
the category that we filter on is the
collection and that is our foreign key
so remember when we created our table
piece
we had a foreign key named collection so
we are seeing if collection
is equal to c item then extract that
particular object from
our table piece and then we will return
this
again through the render method pass the
request
and in here we'll have the path
to an html file just like we did in the
previous case
but this time a different html file
because we want to display this slightly
differently
and then finally we need to pass the
context
so we haven't created the context yet
which we will
now although this is just one item every
time we are passing it through the
render function
you need to make a dictionary out of it
so just copy paste this here
name this p item
pass in here p item
and just now i did create a html file in
the same path as before
that is under templates you have the
genre folder and under that
i created a html file called detail
template
nothing's filled yet but now that we
have created a file
we can put in the path here so just copy
paste this
and change the genre to detail so
that's done too now all we have left
is to actually code the html file
so i'll just copy paste this
here and then make the required
correction
so in p item
and this would be piece object
you align its center and piece
obj is the cover we do not really need
a href here so delete that part out
because this is the final page we are
not redirecting to any other page from
here
of course when you're building a
complete web page
this ideally when you click on the name
of an article
the article should open we wouldn't be
including that part here though because
it does not bring out any new
functionality of django
peace obj and here so peace
obj dot title
dash and then we'll print out the
author or the artist name so peace
obj dot artist
and finally we can have the year also
what
this particular article is that is the
type
so that's pretty much it we'll change
the title to
so now that this is done we'll just
end the for loop
also this is not call cover but now we
got to change it to piece cover
and now we'll go back to our browser so
this is our genre page
refresh it once again and we'll click on
one of the genres and yeah as you see
the particular piece related to that
genre
gets displayed the pet symmetry by
stephen king which is a novel
published in the year 1983. so now we're
back to our code
and well our first and our second page
is designed it's working fine
so now we are not going to create
something new
instead what is already created let's
modify that
now so far the functions that we wrote
work just fine but django provides this
thing called
generic classes or generic views what
this
does is it makes writing these functions
extremely easy so now you have four
lines of code
the exact same thing can be done in like
two or three lines of code
in fact it's not just the easier method
this is also recommended
so i'll tell you how that is done first
of all we need to import the
generic package so from django
dot views import
generic and now let's delete this
entire thing
so our first function is basically
listing out
all the objects in the table so you have
multiple objects all of them are being
listed
out now this kind of a function
would belong to a generic class
so far i was defining functions now i'm
speaking about class
so is it a function or a class well it
is a class
it's definitely a class but i'll show
you how this class
is called as a function so first we'll
finish writing the class
now we have the class index and this
particular class
type is a list view because we are
listing out objects
now under this first we'll have a
template name
which is the path to our template
and now to return our query set
so previously we were always returning a
dictionary now we can return a query set
we have a function def query set
and under this we just say return
collection dot objects dot
all so the same query we were using
previously but
now we do not need to take the objects
from the query and then convert them
into a dictionary
then pass it on using the render
function
we can simply do this one statement and
all our objects
will be sent to our template where
now in the template so far we were
seeing all collection because
that is the key that we were using in
our dictionary
but that is no more we are not using the
render function anymore
when this query set passes an
object it's received by the template
file
in a variable named object list
so you replace your previous variable
with
object list and that is it
with that we finished the method
for displaying our first page now we'll
move on to the second page
so the second page is slightly different
because this time we are not listing out
multiple
objects we just have one object and we
are basically giving out the details of
the object
that means that this class
which we'll still call details is
a detailed view class so we say
generic dot detail view
let's delete all of this first now the
function of this detail view is
basically
to display the details of an object
so what we need to do is first we need
to define a model
now our model is collection because we
are receiving
the primary key from the collection and
each of this object
actually is a part of a collection the
object would not
exist if the related or the counterpart
genre of that object did not exist so
our model is collection
and our template name will be again the
path
so that genre detail template
dot html and that's it so this is
even smaller than our generic view
now in a detailed template initially we
had the name of the key
in our dictionary again this time we
don't have a dictionary pass
so what is the value here well the value
here
would be collection dot piece
underscore set dot all so
this will return all the pieces related
to that particular collection
and everything in small this time now we
are
almost done go back to your views and
you see this is
a generic detail view now the thing
about the detail view class is
it always accepts one parameter go back
to your urls file as you are passing
here a variable gen
genre underscore id of in type you don't
need to do that anymore you can
simply say pk and pk will be passed
to this class and now that's the problem
so here we were calling functions but
now we have classes defined not
functions anymore so we need to figure
out a way
of calling this class as a function so
for that
you just say as underscore view
for both of these classes and that's
it as simple as that now you can call
your classes
as a function and since you use the
generic view now things have become
so much more simpler much smaller our
code looks
very neat now let's go back to our
browser
go to our front page let's see if
everything is displayed right
yes it is so our changes worked out just
fine
click on one of these tags and as you
can see the page has loaded
so much less code very few lines of code
but
things work just as fine as before so
web page is all built
but let's add something new over here to
make it look a little more like a
website
one of the most common things that you
find in every website you go to
is a navigation bar so let's add the
navigation bar
go back to your code now in here
we need a navigation bar in both our
pages
so typically what you might think is the
way to go about it
is add the code for navigation bar in
your genre template
and detail template but as you know
whenever you code
repeatability is something that you
should be always against minimum
repeatability so instead what we do
is under genre the same folder that has
all our templates
create another html file and name this
base so this will be our base template
and we will add the code for creating a
navigation bar in here
and then we'll just include this base in
our other templates
so first let's create our navigation bar
now we'll be using bootstrap to create
the navigation bar
and every time you work with bootstrap
the first thing you need to do
is in your head section include these
three links
so if you have worked with bootstrap you
probably already know you need to go to
the
bootstrap website copy these links paste
them here so you're basically
able to access some style sheets which
are stored in some other system
and once that's done you can start
building
your navigation bar so in your body
you have nav class
navbar and nav bar
default so this
is the class for creating your basic
navigation bar
but actually we'll go with inverse
instead of default so this has a
dark theme navigation bar it will look
better on our
white background website within this
create a div tag of container fluid so
basically what the container fluid does
is that your navigation bar will occupy
the entire
page and will fit according to the page
width now under this you have
the navbar brand class
and the first icon i want is
my home okay so i put in home here
and when i click on home whatever i want
to be redirected to
whichever page i want to be redirected
to put the link for that
or the url for that in here
and i'd like to be redirected to the
genres page
since that's our home page
now other elements we can include in our
navigation bar
we put them as list elements so class
nav nav bar and we want these elements
to the right
of our navigation bar so we say navbar
right
now i'm not going into the details of
this since
again this is not a part of the django
tutorial
so we'll quickly just create the
navigation bar
now every element to the right will be
listed out
and i'll have a registration button so
that will be
under genre slash register
now i have not created the view for this
url yet in fact
this url is not even identifiable yet
but for now i'll just put that in and
we'll run it all together
and finally at the very right end corner
of my navigation bar
i want to display the username that is
whichever user is currently
going through my website now yeah right
now we have not
designed the features for all of this we
don't have a registration form
itself so a user does not mean anything
to us right now
but very soon i'll show you how you can
create a registration form you can have
users register to it so then this will
start making sense
so we'll say li class and in here
the way you can extract the current user
of your website is you say request dot
user
and that's it that's pretty much all we
need right now
just check all the tags again we have
the navbar
inverse which is the type the look of
our navigation bar
container fluid and here we actually
need to specify that
it's a header so we say diff
class navbar header
well this would be closing right in the
end
so i'll just format this once
and finally down here you insert two
python statements you say
block content
content is a variable so you can have
any other name here
just say block content and then end
block
so why this i'll explain to you in a
while
so basically this entire part creates
your navigation bar
but you require this navigation bar to
be present
in multiple pages so here when you say
block content and end block
it's basically the content that will
fall
in each of the pages so if i go to my
genre template page i can simply include
the base template here
and then everything inside the genre
template page
all this instruction to actually create
that
page will come under a block
so what we'll do here is we'll go to
our template pages and here we will
extend
our base.html file so extends
genre slash base dot
html
and then the body the instructions
within the body
will be the content of the block so you
say
block content
and then end block now we do the exact
same thing with our detail template
so now this way we created a common base
file for our navigation bar and the
content
for each of these templates will be by
turn included within this tag here
so we'll have the navigation bar present
for every page
now when we move back to our browser you
see the change here
there is a navigation bar if you click
on home
will be redirected to our genre page and
then click on one of the categories
and you have been redirected to the next
page
the navigation bar is still present so
we also have a user here
currently the only user we created the
super user
it's the admin this will change soon
once we start registering people
so next step is to create
a form where we can actually have users
register
so for our registration page the first
thing we need to do
is we need to create a url and
go in here let's copy this
line so the recognizable url would just
say register
so it would be genres slash register
and that would call a views
function called userform
and we obviously haven't defined this
class yet so yeah this is also going to
be a class we are going to use the
generic view to create this tool it's
going to be pretty simple
but since it's a class we need to call
it as a function so
as view will still exist and we here
we'll have user form
but before we start actually creating a
view for
the registration page or writing our
html file
we need to create a blueprint for the
form so why
a blueprint for the form when we did not
create a blueprint for our other pages
i'll tell you why but first we need to
comment this particular line
because it will result in an error and
now we'll check out our admin page
yeah so this table here is what we'll be
using to store
our usernames so the tables already
present here
we'll just tweak it a little that is
we'll take the username we'll take the
email address and we'll take a password
field
all of these actually have a password if
you click on them you can see here
the password is hashed so these are the
three fields that we'll collect from the
user
so we'll use the basic form just
selecting exactly what we need
so for that purpose we need to create
the blueprint
so to create the blueprint under genre
create a python file calling it forms
and now in here
we import that table we just saw that
database so we say
dot contrib dot or
dot models import
user two imports here
so and then we'll import the module
forms okay so now we can create a class
called userform which will
import from forms dot
model form
and in here we'll have a class called
meta so meta basically means the
definition
or a description of your class so inside
our class user form we'll have a
description for our class
and in that description we give a model
name
so model name is user because we'll be
using that particular model i just
showed you
and then we'll specify the fields that
we'll be using from
this model because we are not taking all
the fields we are going to ignore a few
of them
so we say fields create a list here and
within the list
we'll enter the name of the attributes
that we'll be actually using for our
particular form
so we have username email and we'll take
a password
now unlike username and email password
is not just any care field
so over here we have to specify the
password type
so you say forms dot care field
and within brackets you say widget equal
to
forms dot password import so
password input so from this your django
will know that here we basically need to
take the hashed values
and not just store what the user inputs
as
characters so that's it with that we
have created the blueprint of our form
next thing is we can actually go to the
views
and begin writing the view
the class view for our form
so the class to create a form would be
called user form
view actually before we proceed we need
to
import this so let's do that first
import user form also need to import
some
other packages here we'll import a few
packages for user authorization
that's authenticate
and login
and now we can begin writing a user form
view class
so to use a form you you pass the object
view
and we also need to import a class for
this so
let's do that
from chango dot views
or generic import view okay so the first
thing we need to define
a class for this form
and that would be the user form
and once again a template for this form
which will define the outlook this form
has
so you give a template name which is a
variable name actually you can have any
variable name here just something that
makes sense
now i don't have a template page already
so i've not
as i have not created another html file
for the form
specifically but i know that i'll be
creating it the
genre slash and the name of the html
file
so that would be form template now the
minute we are done writing this view
i'll show you how we do the
template that's just basic html code so
i'm pretty sure you know how to work
with that too
now with forms there are two things
there's the get
method that is basically when the user
wants a form
so you give the user an empty form and
there's a post method that is when the
user puts in
his or her details into the form so
with our class with our generic classes
these methods are already defined and
within two three lines you can
completely define the functionality of
these
so first is the get method to which we
pass
self and request
now the first thing is you provide the
form to the user
and this form is empty so you say self
dot form
class and you pass nothing to this
because as i mentioned earlier too the
form is empty
and now what you do is you return this
object
through the render function so basically
when you do this
the form is combined with the html file
and an object is returned
so basically when you do this what
happens is as i mentioned
earlier too the render function works in
the same way it passes
the object of the form the content of
the form
to the template and it basically sends
out a http
request
so that's your template name and then
finally the form itself
and as we did previously this will be a
dictionary
and that is the get function
now we'll move on to the post
again you pass self and request
now when the user enters the data and
then hits the submit button that's when
the post function will be called
all the data will be stored in a
particular data variable
and that is what we'll be defining the
first line so
form equal to self dot
form class and request
dot post so all your data will go into
this
post variable
now the next thing that the post
function has to do
is check if the data entered by the user
does make sense
so for that you say if form dot is valid
so if the form is valid save this data
so you say form dot save
so where exactly are we saving this well
as i showed you previously
uh django provides this table for
user this database for storing the users
and the group users
so that is exactly where we'll be
storing the data received
through this particular form now
if the data is valid we can separate out
the
various fields receive their clean
format
so first we have our username say
username
equal to form dot cleaned data
and that will be username
and then you have the password
so remember when the user entered the
data itself it was stored in these
fields
but now we're getting a clean version of
that data and storing it
in this these variables username and
password
and now unlike how we can
usually put the equal to sign and assign
values to certain variables this
kind of a process is not possible for
passwords
because passwords are not just storing
some cad field data
it has a hash value i'll show you that
once again
so you see here you go to the users
admin
and if you check this out the password
is not actually stored as just
characters
it's hashed using some algorithm and
then it's stored so in this particular
case we cannot say that password
is equal to this value there's a certain
function through which you pass the
password
such that it's stored in the required
format
so for that you say user dot set
password and then you pass
password variable and finally you see
user dot
save so guys over here
actually we are saving the data
in the shell not in your database
and once our data is cleaned and
everything it is then that we are saving
it into the database
so that's why we have two save
statements here so now that the user has
entered their data
and they have hit the submit button we
have saved the data
in our database what's next well now
what we want to do
is we need to redirect the user to the
index page
basically once the user is done with the
registration
process there's no point of the user
staying on the same page again
so we redirect them to the index page
now along with this we'll also combine
login so if the user's password and
username are authenticated
and the user is in active status that
means
that the user has logged into our
website so now we'll see how this is
done
create a object new user and this
object will hold a user if
the username and the password that we
pass here to this authenticate function
is actually valid and they match
that is the form of that is they form a
pair
so the username will be the variable
username
and password will be the variable
password
so if the new user does exist that is if
new user is not null
if the new user is not none we'll check
the stages of the new user so what is
the status again i'll take you back to
that database
go to users well since we're in the
middle of the code we cannot
access this page but basically this
database
or this table which stores the usernames
has a field called status which you
probably would have noticed and next to
the
active user there's a green tick so if
the user has that green tick if the user
is active
that means his session is in progress so
it's basically like logging in
so you say if new user dot
is active
you log in the user you send request
and the new user object
and once the user has logged in you
return the user to the index page
and this is where you need to use a
function redirect
before we use that function we need to
of course import it
so here or redirect is within this
same shortcuts library
we'll just add and redirect here
so index page is basically called genre
so
that's where the user will be taken
now if this user is not authenticated
that is there is some
invalid data entered we basically give
the user
back a form an empty form give them
another chance to fill it
so for that we just copy paste this line
here
the render put that down there
and that's it with that we are done
creating a view
for our user form now what we are left
with is actually creating this html file
so let's do that again go to genre your
main folder and
create a html file now remember what we
named
a html file in this view that's form
template
make sure it's the same name
so let's start creating the form the
first thing we do
is for the form 2 we want to add the
navigation bar
so go to your go to any of your html
files and copy out these lines here
registration then you have the block
content which is exactly where you'll be
putting all your content
that goes here and then we'll start
and then we'll add the end block
again copy paste that too okay
so now we can start typing out our html
code
so first is our form tag
now this is going to be an extremely
simple straightforward form
and now the thing with django is
whenever you're having a form
an interactive form make sure to include
this
csrf token here so csrf
stands for cross site request forgery
that can be sent actually from and it's
a type of cross
site scripting attack that can be sent
from malicious site
through your visitors browser to your
own server
so to prevent this django provides a
very simple technique
which is where you provide this csrf
token
now make sure you're always providing
this whenever you have a post method
and you're not redirecting or you're not
using the url of
or you're not using an external url
because that means
that your current page csrf token
is being sent to an external web page
and obviously that kind of a leakage
would hamper the security
okay so we'll be taking a username
again email is also type text
and finally the password
and after all the fields you have
finally the submit button
and that's it so our html page
is also ready now so now you need to
move
on to the urls page and uncomment this
because now we actually have a response
also this is called user form view now
i'll just stop the server and run it
again although this is not really
necessary if you just go back to your
page refresh it
everything works fine
okay now we will move on to our web page
okay so home page is working fine just
like before
next you click on register and here's
your form
so as you can see here the navigation
bar is present for the form too
now we'll create a new user
name simply with the email id simply123
gmail.com and password
that's it now click the submit button
and the minute we click the submit
button as you can see you got
transferred back to the home page
and in here if you see the right hand
corner you'll notice that we had admin
before but now it's simply
so that is because we just now created a
user simply
and the minute you create a user by
default that becomes the active user
now to check this we will move on to the
admin page
and this is our landing page so now what
happened is that since the other user
that we newly created
is the active user that means we got
logged out of the
admins profile and to view the admin
page of course we need to be logged in
as the admin
so i log back in and as you can see here
under the users group you'll notice we
have a new user created
simply with the following email id
so that's it guys so with that we come
to an end to tutorial on
django if you have any doubts please
leave them in the comment section below
and we'll definitely get back to you
also if you like the video please hit
the like button and also subscribe to
our channel if you haven't yet
so keep learning and see you all next
time
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here